we've all grown up hearing that
Disneyland is the happiest place on
earth but what if we told you it was
also the happiest haunted place on earth
keep watching to learn who's the most
famous person that is said to have taken
up residence at Disneyland after his
passing now let's check out all the best
theories about the ghosts that haunt
Disneyland in 1955 a magical thing
happened the original Disney theme park
opened in Anaheim California but as
Disneyland grew so did the stories about
supernatural experiences both guests and
cast members at Disneyland have shared
stories about ghostly things going on so
much so that the list of ghosts that
allegedly haunted Disneyland has grown
to quite a link there are theories that
will make your toes curl and will
documented tragedies that will bring
tears to your eyes you might want to
take some of these theories with a pinch
of salt but you can't deny their totally
intriguing you can categorize the
different haunting theories into four
main groups you've got the ones based on
actual historic events that really
happened at Disneyland like the tragic
accidents of visitors and employees
while they were on a ride or working
then there are the ghostly figures that
come from urban legends which often have
different versions we've also got the
rides themselves that can behave in
creepy ways and finally there are the
theories based on families that
apparently scattered the ashes of their
loved ones we're starting with the
tragedies when people lost their lives
at Disneyland and the hauntings that are
claimed to have happened since Thomas
Cleveland the first real incident
involves the monorail ghost this figure
was Thomas guy Cleveland a 19 year old
who is reported to have tried to sneak
into Disneyland
in 1966 he did so by climbing over the
parks perimeter fence and in going along
the monorail track it said that he's
stuck in two attends the grad night
event and the park stays open all night
for high school graduates a park
security guard apparently saw him and
called at him to get down but he was
still on the track when the tram struck
him and dragged him under its for
carriages following the passing there
were reports that the spectral figure is
sometimes seen at night around the
monorail track some say they've seen him
running alongside the trains while
others say that whenever a tram
approaches the monorail
ghost vanishes Debby stone a Disneyland
employee was tragically crushed in 1974
while working at the park
Debbie stone was 18 years old when she
was a hostess at the America sings
attraction she got caught between the
rotating wall and the stage wall in the
theater various changes were made
afterward to stop such a tragic event
from ever occurring again the solid
walls were replaced with a breakaway
ones a safety light was put in to warn
the operator when anyone got too close
to the area and it said that after her
passing
Debbie herself played a part and keeping
other safe cast members who worked on
the attraction are said to have heard a
voice telling them to be careful when
they got too close to the walls
the attraction eventually closed in the
late 80s we hope Debbie was then able to
rest in peace knowing that no one else
would be subject to the same fate as her
it's reassuring to hear a haunting
theory that involves a Friendly Ghost
Regina dolly young a 48 year old visitor
to Disneyland was fatally hurt when she
was hit by another bobsled after she
fell from her seat while riding the
Matterhorn in 1984 Regina yongku is
known as dolly had an unbuckled seatbelt
when she fell it's not known why she
wasn't safely harnessed in but there are
theories that she had unbuckled herself
to check on a child who was sitting
alone in the front seat dolly was alone
in the back seat this idea of dolly
watching over others has extended into
the ghost story that grew out of her
tragic fate while doing their routine
walkthroughs of the ride at the end of
the day some cast members have claimed
it felt like something was watching them
and a former cast member who worked at
Disney Land as an attractions hostess in
the early 90s said the uneasy feeling
she got was always worse in the big
cavern in the middle of the ride where
dolly died while it's impossible to
prove something like this what is a fact
is at the area on the track where the
accident happened became known as
Dolly's death these three real-life
tragic events have all resulted in
haunting theories let us know in the
comments which ghostly apparition you
think sounds most convincing it's now
time to move on to all those urban
legends lady in white if ever there's an
iconic haunting figure it's the alleged
woman in white and Disneyland has its
very own lady in white she supposedly
been spa
walking along Main Street wandering past
the stores you might be thinking that a
woman wearing all white doesn't
necessarily have to be a ghost but this
lady in white seems to hark back to the
olden times and she's wearing clothing
from the early 1900's and legend has it
that she died on the site at the turn of
the 20th century before the park was
even built but she never left the
property and stayed after the rides
arrived one theory is that she never
left because she liked the old fashioned
feel of Main Street
this ghostly apparition dressed in the
Victorian outfit does more than just
walk around though it said she actually
helps lost children find their way to
guest services to be reunited with their
parents at least this ghost isn't one
that makes you turn away in horror
there's another friendly apparition that
likes to chat with modern day visitors
let's meet him now
mr. one way Space Mountain is one of the
most famous attractions at Disneyland
and mr. one-way is one of the most
talked-about ghost stories like other
urban legends this one has many
variations which makes people believe
it's not actually true one version of
Mister one way is a child dressed in 70s
clothes he supposedly speaks to people
who are waiting in line for the ride
another count is that Mister one way is
a red-haired man with a red face this
version also hangs out in the line but
doesn't chat to the living visitors in
the park there's also video footage
showing mr. one-way approaching the cars
from the side of the waiting area where
you're meant to exit he sits down in
empty seat next to a single rider but
disappears just before the final tunnel
one theory is that this is the ghosts of
a man who died on the ride in the 70s
he's also apparently been spotted in the
cast member locker rooms in the Space
Mountain building these ghostly figures
are urban legends that get passed around
amongst Disney fans and create lots of
debate what are your thoughts on these
theories be sure to tell us in the
comments and now we get to learn about
the rumors surrounding the supernatural
sounds that have followed reports of
Ashes being scattered at Disneyland
Haunted Mansion boy Disneyland as many
people's favorite place so it's no
wonder that so many fans love the idea
of having their ashes scattered at the
park and it's also no surprise that this
has led to some eerie haunting tales
it's worth sayings like Disneyland
doesn't actually allow the remains to be
scattered on its property but that
didn't stop a little boys mom supposedly
spreading his ashes in the Haunted
Mansion without permission that's a
pretty appropriate ride to pick right
it's at his dying wish was to be one of
the ghosts in the attraction so his
mother's snuck back in and scattered his
ashes in the ride legend has it is that
the boy's ghost has been heard crying
for his mother at the end of the ride
the same ghost has also allegedly been
spotted at Pirates of the Caribbean ride
next door to there are certain rides
like these too that have various
haunting theories let's delve deeper
haunted ride theories this little boy
isn't the only ghost that said to haunt
the Haunted Mansion
when it was being built in the 60s a
sound designer reportedly heard music
coming from behind a wall in the seance
room after hearing it for days he masked
to the spooky sound by putting the
speaker near it there were also rumors
amongst cast members that the spell book
in seance circle was real apparently
each morning cast members would find the
book in a different place to where it
had been left to the night before that's
not the only object that's said to be
haunted how about a whole cast of
figurines it's a small world
this one is a case of truth being
stranger than fiction or actually
inspiring fiction the author Ridley
Pearson published a series of books
called the Kingdom Keepers which were
set in the Disney parks these thrillers
are pretty freaky and one scary scene
was actually inspired by a real-life
experiences of the authors when Disney
invited him to write a thriller set
inside the theme parks really insisted
he'd have to have full access to them at
night so a Disney Imagineer showed him
around when the park was closed one
night when he was writing it's a small
world when all the power was off he saw
- animatronic dolls move and that
inspired the scene in his first book
when all of the dolls start moving he
takes things even further by having the
dolls bite at kids there's also a theory
among cast members that some of the
previous employees who worked on it's a
small world loved it so much they came
back to live there after they died the
story goes that the lights turn on and
off and the dolls will keep on dancing
and singing after the electricity has
been
turned off pirates of the Caribbean if
you thought that was a spooky tale about
ghostly props just wait until you hear
about the Pirates of the Caribbean ride
you'd assume that the bones and
skeletons used in the set for this
popular ride were fake right actual real
bones were used as props in the
Disneyland ride when it was built in
1967 it was the late pride that Walt
Disney himself supervised more on him
later
although Walt loved it to the design
team was disappointed when the faux
skeletons of the period didn't live up
to their realism of the rest of the
experience they found that fake bones
were too unconvincing so they did what
any imagined air would do and got some
actual skeletons from their friends at
UCLA Medical Center's anatomy department
the new generation of Imagineers
eventually found realistic fakes and
replaced the real ones which were then
given a proper burial but some people
including former Disney employees
insists that a few of the real deals
still remain such as the skull and the
crossbones
set over the dead captain's bed as if
that wasn't enough there's also a theory
that there's a boy ghost that can be
seen in the control tower caught on
surveillance cameras if this is true at
least they claim is that he always seems
to be happy and enjoying himself all
rumors claim Walt Disney's ghost haunts
the Disney gallery above pirates the
theory goes that the gallery was
originally designed to be Walt's
personal apartment since the one above
the main street fire station was on the
small side Walt Disney speaking of the
man himself it's now time for the final
ghosts that is said to haunt Disneyland
and we've saved the best or most famous
to last allegedly his old second-floor
apartment above the firehouse is the
location for his haunting ways he used
to stay there when visiting the park and
he would let everyone know he was there
by lighting a lamp in the window Disney
Legend has taken this story and run with
it all the way to a theory that Walt's
ghost still resides there now after he
died a cleaner was in the apartment when
she noticed the lamp was lit she turned
it off and left but when she got outside
she noticed it was lit in the window
again
she returned to turn it back off the
same thing happened when she left so she
tried a third time to switch it
and stayed in the apartment to see the
lamp turn itself back on there's even a
legend that she's heard someone say the
words I'm still here and now the lamp is
left burning to symbolize Walt's
presence cast members have added fuel to
the fire by claiming to hear footsteps
and knocking coming from the firestation
apartment at night what do you think
about all these theories which
Disneyland ghosts do you think sounds
most likely to be real sound off with
your own fan theories in the comments
section below and that's it for all the
best haunted Disneyland theories give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe thanks for watching
[Music]